jeudi soir dans un café de la capitale
américaine
ils sont quelques dizaines à venir
écouter sur écran leur idole qui parle
d' urgence climatique et de combat
contre la guerre une petite foule aux
couleurs des années 70 et puis elle fait
une brève apparition
jen forme d'art l'actrice mais surtout
la révolutionnaire qui prônent
aujourd'hui la désobéissance civile pour
changer les choses ce matin et le
manifeste pour la cinquième semaine de
suite devant le congrès américain
inspiré par great attenberg et le milite
contre l'inaction des gouvernements dans
la lutte aux changements climatiques
parmi la foule plusieurs générations qui
milite à ses côtés et nous inspire
autant que greta dit kathleen domanski
c'est une femme que j'admire depuis des
années 60 explique sarah shaw jane fonda
actrice deux fois oscarisée a épousé
bien des causes depuis des décennies
entre autres celle des amérindiens et
surtout celle contre la guerre au
vietnam où elle s'était rendue pour y
rencontrer des soldats ennemis des
américains ce qui lui a valu le surnom
de hanoi j'ai aujourd'hui cela fait deux
mois qu'elle a déménagé à washington
avec un objectif précis
se faire arrêter pour désobéissance
civile afin d'attirer les projecteurs
sur la lutte aux changements climatiques
et cette course effrénée vers l'armement
cela fait donc quatre vendredi que la
police lui passe les menottes car il n'a
pas de permis pour manifester chaque
fois elle se fait prendre les empreintes
digitales reste quelques heures en
prison pour ensuite ressortir après
avoir payé la somme de 50 $ pour son
délit car ce n'est pas un crime
voir son mouvement grandir de semaine en
semaine semble satisfaire la crise
américium êtes vous satisfait de la
manifestation à la fois en route donc
vers sa prochaine arrestation
hebdomadaire le 21 décembre
jane fonda manifestera le jour de son
anniversaire et laura 82 ans ici
frédéric arnould radio-canada washington